a lot of people they are challenged by
people who work and think outside of the
box a lot of people aren't necessarily
rooting for you to do well or to do good
those people the thing they always ask
is oh but the travel right right it
seems like you're having a lot of fun
you're in front of a lot of people
you're hanging with the funniest people
in the world it's got to be the travel
right well let's break that down the
travel right me and you probably take a
town car to the airport I'm guessing you
fly first class we fly first class to
another town where there's a limo
waiting for us at the airport takes us
to a five-star hotel and we tell jokes
for the weekend and eat for free let's
talk about your travel every day how
about your two hour commute every day to
your office to your cubicle where you
hate your job you hate your life so
who's got the worst travel me or you
there